giorno numero uno del blog ma non so
cosa però so solo che sono qui con lui
al base per il fox circus e sto e con i
capelli bagnati e dei cinque gradi al
sole quindi bene così mi sa che non
arriviamo umani entriamo entriamo ti
prego bisogno di un riscaldamento
applicato se ci fosse stata una gene fox
ma si è riportato a casa
[Musica]
[Applauso]
credo che il fatto di non aver asciugato
i capelli non sia stata un'idea
intelligente perché adesso siamo morti a
letto ed è che le sono scusa se le
quattro e mezza
il motivo di questo blog mans e che di
base io non non sono fan del natale il
natale mette molta malinconia
non so perché quindi ho deciso che
quella scusa del blog ma se adesso
appena torno a roma
dovrò per forza vivere lo spirito
natalizio natale bello sì però non ti
mette anche a te cosa fate piacere nuovo
perché oggi è un momento questa
l'insieme famiglia se maglia tanto sarà
natale poi puoi fare sono più puri cioè
natale e sdegno apocalisse almeno ti
senti ti senti nemmeno ti sbagli un po
di più
ok ok l'avresti ficato e natale rimanga
bravo in una lettera dieta ma se così
torino amore siamo così carini to di più
no no no intendevo che ormai siamo i due
che a guardà ripreso tutto alta posi
ammettiamolo dobbiamo per andare a cena
e lui mi vuole portare in un posto dice
che sushi ma non è non è un olio finita
assolutamente no superbuono pene sarà la
mia prima volta che vado a mangiare un
suo sceglierne uno giovinetta chissà voi
ci si sente da ricchi come funziona e
come funziona vorrei dire sederti su una
sede da parteciperemo tavolo ti
portavano del cibo dovremmo integrando
le bacchette e al massimo potrà
intingere una società che si chiama soia
è certo stenting zandoli due bacchette
nella polemica vedo già ne vale la pena
sfida di lo si era stato qualsiasi
contratto le maniere
come si chiamano si chiama io po ma lei
è super carina e super giusta super
giusta ma come barry e lo stesso per
carine super giusta e yo yo yo usate
ragazzi e super giusta yo yo yo yo mi
prende sempre in giro come no vestire
stasera carino super giusto ogni odio
york non ci penso io quindi sicuramente
sarai super visto io voglio io
se guardavo cantante mi piace un sacco
come giusto bieber e io lo zuccherino
altri fornitori tre bombe no non è vero
già una mano in area ma anche per casoli
addormenta
ma è anche uscito il video chi è
riuscito a strappare i sex and the city
che dopo una ragazza mi ha chiesto di
vedere i blu per sé i blu per cosa sono
i cui le opere dei cugini dei puffi eco
blue me un po più alti i blu persone gli
errori
si vede si vede mai pensavo fossi un
[ __ ] invece li solo un po confuso
non è vero sì dài nelle donne serie non
non dovrebbero fare sesso ma ciò detto
spezzina inzio alle banane i guardiani
con il funzionario un'altra cosa ma e
braidese mangiare tutti
perché tutti
crescere grazie mille è stato un piacere
tesoro
grazie mille e stato un piacere grazie
grazie mille piacere
azione
mamma
stiamo andando a mangiare un sushi molto
buono e per la prima volta non è un look
enit quindi mangerà pochissimo portiamo
al sushi
dopo le ore di peregrinare per crepe
luigi non sa usare google maps l'odio e
io odio tema no vabbè non bello ha preso
una saletta praticamente solo per noi
perché conosce ed è amico di rosi che è
la proprietaria di questo posto è
praticamente tutto questo post è
solamente per noi così metteteli rosi e
lei la nostra donna tutti preparati i
ragazzi perché stasera di ogni modo
stomaco mal in tribuna
20 c in centro
con barbe e alla serata carina è legata
romantica che cos'è che ha detto che è
questo il letto di salmone del salmone
compiuto di posto cosa con mediterraneo
chiesa per quei giovani che ho uno che
sa che una macchina amber salmone
roberti capo di cose buone che luigino
può mangiare perché allergico neppure
sfocato anche la camera di odio tonno ai
sapori mediterranei baubeach manzo
verdure stavo lottando
[Musica]
avresti avuto piatto carpaccio di
gamberi così siciliana e tu non lo
mangerà il perché lo mangerà ce l'ho io
sarah si butta per averlo reso leggevo e
gamberi per fortuna no non mi sa che
brutto se messo all'immaginario mio dio
oh mio dio abbiamo in realtà già
intagliato questa cosa che sto cercando
di metterci una pezza come la differente
angolazione riso lo zafferano con
gambero tutto mio peso quello dovrò
dividere con il salmone con la riccia
dovrò dividerlo e poi c'è lui ken dorato
fuori cia gordio
e questo è tutto mio perché scelga
presero un mezzo raptus ci siamo messi a
suggere questo assassino
apple e moto e rotolini di pesce spada
con dentro il formaggio francese e di
organizzarlo figurazione ci vogliono
uccidere la morte non è mai stata così
dolce che cosa abbiamo qui tagliolini al
nero di seppia con un nuovo e bacon
ecco apoteosi muovono dai bando fallo
perché sono quelle
non restano napolatana non fu fondandovi
la passione nostra un anno a fuoco la
bassa
ok la sua morte lascia tutti c'era
chiesto il dolce dolce resto sono
intelligente negli occhi
ecco i premi benedire dal buddha abbiamo
ordinato dolce e ci hanno detto che ci
sono ancora due piatti però da
assaggiare stiamo per morire è una
serata romantica un uomo distrutto
a chiarirlo non faceva ridere fatto
organi una zucchina ripiena ho scritto
questo nuovo viaggio abbiamo dei
rotolini
ronnie asparagi e vapori carpaccio di
perché si articola in tre aree al
comitato dodi l'unità 15 abbiamo lo
stesso intonato un crepaccio di tonno e
carta di tonno leggendo i nomi caldi
della sardegna è guasta mai al live
questa è una rapina micciola ignorata
emulsione dirige mare fortorina certo
bolzano e questo è certo lido con il
salmone tartare di salmone ha detto
acquistate grazie noi
sto morendo non avrei mai pensato per
capire di non riesco più parlare cioè
scusate
[Musica]
quando abbiamo paura ha detto laporta si
sa è stata una cena antonio di bella
devo ancora devono arrivare dove al
centro
brutto sogno di una vacca scoprendo
[Musica]
la vita
un collo cercherò di togliere il fatto
che sono rossissimo metterò un filtro
super fred la grazia non me l'aspettavo
ma per il partito detto ok caso in
italia nostra canzone di fischi ogni
draghi
allora questa qui è una specie di donut
con cioccolato al latte crumble cos'è
arachidi sala laghi questo si chiama il
mondo trova spazio una cosa di
cioccolato come sotto scacco tuo
aspettava che mamma ok ok tiro santo
un dio santo ti amo bocciolone
[Musica]
la
i praticanti
la cosa più dolce come non mai fatto il
mi confronto dentro di te lo meriti
arrivato non sembra compare come siamo
tornati a casa e luigi mi ha fatto una
sorpresa bellissima oddio ma che cosa
sembra una ripresa di the blair witch
project
volevo chiedere scusa la mamma di joss
poiché aver covato stabon mi ha fatto
una sorpresa molto bella se è contento
ma quando lei pianificata questione
mettendo in difficoltà perché adesso
anticato per fare qualcosa meno c'è
all'altezza chi dovrà impegnare direi
che questa prima puntata del blog mas
finisce qui non so se i blog si facciano
così domani torno pure a roma quindi non
so che cosa farò in treno l'unica cosa
sicura è che ci vediamo comunque domani
con un altro vlog mas alle 14 che culo
della di voi buona cucina trascura una
mamma di più